jake ton père a toujours dit qu'il
voulait que tu sois pilotes
il a dit plein de trucs mais je suis pas
un héros comme lui
les kaiju ils vont se reporter et je
serai pas coincée attendre que quelqu'un
vienne me sauver cadets préparez vous
[Musique]
ça c'est la fin du mental
comment ils sont entrés dans notre monde
quelqu'un les a fait entrer quelqu'un
qui appartient à notre monde
sept-îles ça en tout cas c'est pas un
des nôtres
tu as une occasion de te rattraper
il nous faut plus de pilote
on les a
certains pilotes sont devenus des
légendes mais ils ne sont pas les héros
ils ont commencé comme nous aujourd'hui
nous allons changer les choses
est ce que c'est bien clair
pilote de jager parce que c'est bien
clair on va bientôt le savoir
j'essaierai jobs
[Musique]
la journée va être longue on sait quoi
on se bat